so
you guys are pretty frisky today you can
tell they're wild animals so dinner is
served
animal keeper Rene Volta thought he knew
what horses like to eat but today
they're even ignoring their favorite
food carrots the last of these horses
was captured in the 1960s and taken to a
zoo they would have died out of European
zoos hadn't developed an extensive
breeding program humans nearly wiped
them out so it was up to humans to save
them people took over the horses natural
habitat and hunted them to the point
where they nearly became extinct that's
why you don't find them in the wild
anymore then people at zoos and similar
facilities felt obligated to try and
help them to return to nature just like
they've done with other species affinity
network but behavioral biologist dr.
Anna Berger says teaching them to
survive on their own is going to require
a lot of work some of the horses are
housed on this game Preserve near Berlin
they're fenced in for their own safety
new horses have a hard time fitting in
here for example it doesn't occur to
them to put on extra fat as winter
approaches they used to life at the zoo
where they get regular meals and they
figure it's too much work to put on all
that fat for winter so they stroll
around the meadows instead they don't
take things seriously during the first
year but they sure do during the second
scientists have conducted extensive
research to try to determine exactly how
the Przewalski's horses will have to
adapt to be able to survive in the wild
they've outfitted this trough with
various devices that allow them to find
out how much water each individual horse
drinks a scale in the floor measures the
horses weight gain as they drink dr.
Berger says horses that drink a lot of
water
wouldn't do well in a natural
environment that's dry there are other
problems like the horses hooves that
would complicate life in the wild the
vaccine than running inside at certain
times of the year their hooves grow way
too long that makes it really difficult
for them to run properly they slow down
and trip over their own legs that makes
it tough for them to survive in the wild
it makes them easy prey for predators
the Przewalski's horses are native to
the steppes of Central Asia and
specifically Mongolia there the horses
are called tucky which means spirit
efforts continue to resettle the horses
in their natural habitat but there have
been problems at first the horses
couldn't adapt to extreme mongolian
winters and many of them died but they
learned to adapt to the weather to
predators and to the inhospitable
landscape there are now an estimated
3,000 Chbosky horses worldwide dr.
Berger is pretty pleased about that
she's known this horse called Elina
for 22 years Elina will probably stay
here at the game reserve near Berlin for
the rest of her life but some of the
other animals may be sent to Mongolia it
won't be easy for dr. Berger to see them
go it's like when your children leave
home you're both happy and sad
perhaps dr. burger and other experts can
apply the lessons they've learned here
to help preserve other endangered
animals